[Music]
all right and we all love our in our
with the Lord's returns for some
Skywalker Star Wars action without
action for a little bit but oh we gotta
talk about it man fresh out the theater
shout out the I pick for letting us do
this but I solve katsu in the building
let's go y'all
so we gonna get right to it now look I
am the sword fraud so I'm gonna defer to
you my feelings will be last
I'm gonna defer to the expert the man of
Medicare knows whatever that is we're
gonna defer so slow song let's start
with you we just saying it riser to
Skywalker
give me those raw thoughts - I'm gonna
say this I'm not I'm a fraud in the
sense that I don't I'm at wash so the
movies I understand the movies but
beyond that I don't know or follow
anything of the universe beyond that so
it's a lot of details in the universe
and I don't particularly know about or
necessarily care about you know this 9
movie orcas is in a lot of ways the arc
of my life yeah of all our lives you
know the series going with 40 years and
some grew up with this exactly so I'm
gonna be honest - I thought it was not a
great ending to the series Oh in case
you guys don't know this is a spoiler
well spoiler kappa sorry um the first
thing that I felt that they did wrong
was I think the Palpatine reveal in the
marketing early on was stupid mmm
way way I just feel like they start the
movie off already
with
pétain haven't made his return known
already well and it takes away some of
the gravity of that to know that this
villain from so long ago is still
pulling the strings in the background
right it didn't make a lot of sense to
me it took a lot of honestly a lot of
the wind out of the sails in the movie
for me because I I thought it would have
been a much stronger movie if in the
middle of the movie you have that oh ish
boom yeah Palpatine is behind everything
right it was kind of early like early it
was it was too early and I think it took
away a lot of the power and the gravity
of the message of the movie I just
thought in a lot of ways another thing
that I don't like about these trilogies
is the fact that I think we learned from
the Lord of the Rings trilogy you should
keep you should a film them all at the
same time be keep the same director
throughout so that you have unity of
vision consistency and consistency and
it felt in a lot of ways this movie was
trying to write certain wrongs mmm
committed by the last Jedi mmm and it's
and it's again that's a subjective thing
but I think you can tell by what JJ
Abrams did in force awakens and what he
did here there was it felt like some of
it was course-correction
and in doing that again you take away
some of the gravity and the power of a
movie that's supposed to be ending a
nine movie arm
now when you say of course I got a
started for saying when you say course
correction what do you feel that the
error that they were trying to fix that
maybe people were upset about the fact
the entire thing with Luke in in the
last Jedi indicating that the Jedi had
to die um and he continuing to reinforce
that and then in this one the last over
the Jedi it you know I understand that
he I understand the thinking behind it
like the old ways of the Jedi have to
die we have to understand that it's a
bit so it's much more than that
and I think it there's one statement
that he made in the last year that he
said the force never belonged to the
Jedi the
we're able to manipulate but it's it's
much bigger than us and I think I think
rise of Skywalker shows that but I just
think the next cue it was it didn't
execute it it was super fanservice see
in the fact that you know every all all
all storylines the corner sort of tied
off neatly and nicely I honestly was not
happy with the redemption of Ben solo if
you look at all these movies right in
the hero arc right and then in each type
of movie though as you see the villain
arc where especially in Star Wars where
you had the villain arc where this
person meant to be a hero this person
who comes from a lineage of heroes right
it's turned and then right at the end
finds his way back and I just think it's
a corny trope that I wish they would
have stuck to their guns and you Ben
solos gone gotcha
and the fact that he came back was
thoroughly disappointing and then on top
of that he still dies got the redemption
or the crook in top of that he gets he
gets the hero's death okay okay I don't
think he didn't earn that it's one of
those things I rewatched I skim watched
last Jedi this morning kind of and I
think it has better unity of vision at
least within that movie right obviously
you have JJ Abrams Rian Johnson and JJ
Abrams again so there's there's a
disconnect there but I think it's a
singular movie yeah
the message tells it's still more
coherent than this one than this one
there's too many strings I tried they
try to tie up
sounds nothing sorry this over the KY
Basu you know he was sitting right next
to me during this whole thing and uh
there was some commenting and some irony
here and there but overall man this is
now this woulda Clara is this the end of
the the Saugus is it right this is the
Clary this is the I have heard all right
this is the end of the Skywalker saga
hey be they're not doing trilogies
anymore this is do one offs ok but it
won't be anything is looking on a
grander scale is again all rights ok box
before is yours
Barnard the Lord I need to know what you
felt a man rather Scott Walker which
felt well just before I start with this
one thing I just gotta let everyone know
I am a Star Wars frog I've seen all the
movies I enjoyed the original trilogy
although I wasn't one of them I enjoyed
the original trilogy although I wasn't
one of the ones who kind of got
obsessive over it and then the prequel
trilogy my feelings with it was that the
dialogue was absolutely horrible
accorded all but at least a store it's a
stiff well at least the story itself was
coherent that you can understand what
was going on my problem with this
trilogy has always been one thing it
seems like that they has great actors
and they have great acting ability but
the characters themselves they really
seem to have no gravitas to them that
they really had no substance alone and
with Raisa Skywalker it came even more
pronounced and now you have back the man
in McDormand as Emperor Palpatine
he stole every single scene but like the
one thing I was telling you during the
movie he's so good that he makes
everybody else's character look like
broccoli in comparison a clean bland
like why are these people here then for
my main problem in regards to this movie
and this is not even as a Star Wars fan
but just as a person who watches cinema
this Rises Skywalker should have been
broken up into two movies
it was way to rush the first the first
hour jumped from location to location
location and spent part like two to
three minutes
and then it got to the point that there
were certain scenes that you couldn't
understand the progression there's two
things I just want to make a straight
with it one of the scenes was when they
met up we're on the planet so that when
they met up with are on the planet so
that they can unlock the droids mind
right and the thing is was the Pope
they met Paul's girlfriend on the planet
at first she wanted to kill him your
brains will be splattered then then five
minutes later she says like yeah I'm
gonna be leaving soon he's my talking to
get out of get out of his slums and then
five minutes later he gave her she gave
her his only kid honestly I think that
moment it implied obviously history
between them in a way I don't think she
ever wanted to kill him she's mad at him
obviously but I think she's in love with
them and I think I but this it it
doesn't but it doesn't matter because
it's implying Eddie you know what you
know what that's what they went directly
to the mechanic and then they escaped
where is the timing on that that was
literally to be honest that that's a
moment that I feel is well done because
it it's it's a right it's not it's not
telling you everything it's implying it
right it's being smart it's actually
being somewhat respectful of the
audience instead of hey by the way these
two had a relationship before I you know
I get it but you wanna I'm gonna keep it
that one but I'll passed by that then
here's the next one
when they go to shave when they go to
save Chewbacca and they split and they
split up inside of the inside of the
ship and Ray goes to do her thing while
Poe and it's like you forgetting this
name Ben in pole went to go safety vodka
next scene so they went to go save
Chewbacca in the next scene Chewbacca is
fighting with them like when did he get
rescued well I mean but
when in the middle of the rebellion did
Finn have time to start getting dreads
that's what I want yeah but when it
comes down to that comes with my big my
biggest issue with the movie is just
that it jumped around from place to
place to place and it has a bunch of
fanservice moments but without no
without no substance behind him no scene
direction because of them like also like
they had the scene where where kylo he
did the whole Darth Vader choked out the
subordinate they done the ceilings like
it's like it's his fanservice but why
how does it serve the scene it doesn't
they've nearly made the same movie nine
times listen are you I mean look for me
again I'm Star Wars for it casual you
know say like I watch this thing since
growing up as a kid to me Star Wars
always been that feel good in a galactic
story you know against all odds us
against them the evil the dark force to
me like Star Wars is a space movie with
religious strokes like this like this
like religion in throw it's weird so I
you know whole force take it all I get
but um I don't take it too seriously
however I do feel like they try to
fanservice a lot like the the Luke
Skywalker classic ship that whole stuff
and again for me as a casual I get it
and there were some feelings I'm like oh
I remember that okay cool
I could understand though as a hardcore
fan how you could discussed it you know
saying like to me this was the casual
movie for me this was I was like okay I
see what they doing you know I'm not
saying it was a great movie I'm just
saying like to me this is the joint you
take your kids to you know everything
ties up nicely in a bow you're the same
kind of thing as far as the whole kylo
Ren and Rey relationship very strange in
the beginning I thought they were gonna
do one thing let me switch to something
else then okay at the end with the
poverty not agree with you car probably
need to be stole the moolah are mere for
all the poverty scenes you know they all
all the dead like that's my favorite he
because he is the personification of
evil there's no waiver
yes he is he is one of the few
characters it's completely unwavering in
his in in what he is right he wants to
do and everybody else felt conflicted
they it's always a struggle and you know
one minute like they're fighting hard
but they're gonna go to the death next
bit how I'm gonna save you so it's like
that whole dynamic I didn't feel the
payoff was that great it kind of felt a
little flat towards the end you know I'm
saying you know the sacrifice and all
that other stuff you know the other
thing is they straight killing off the
oh jeez oh they ain't got no respect for
those jeez oh jeez I hear you like a
homegirl what so they own yeah she's out
you know shout out the land oh he try to
gauge I get it with the young once live
with a colt 45
shout out to Billy Dee being Billy Dee
in everything it is the same performance
in every movie watch bat watch watch
Batman 1989 is Lando Calrissian is Billy
Dee across this colt 45 Billy Dee is you
know he got me 70 over smooth for you
shout out to Ray for the Rodimus Prime
moment you got the tattoos eat it
I go fries yes all the people that had
two matrix Anita [ __ ] like that was
disgusting once again it's to fan
services and I don't felt I don't feel
that it was earned I can and not that
the character of Ray didn't necessarily
earn to his actual oh no not the
character of Ray didn't earn it in the
movie they named her progression through
the movie didn't naturally lead to to me
to that a point I want to give I would
ask a question in reference to the kylo
Ren character
his ark you know I know when during that
final scene you were groaning we kind of
explaining to me certain things about
you know that whole exchange was very
like what's your whole feeling on his
arc and the ending how do you feel about
that thing is and I know I'm gonna get a
lot of flack for this but for last Jedi
the one thing I was kind of actually
enjoying and I was actually looking
forward to that when they were saying
that they wanted to kill the like they
wanted to end the Jedi line the what I
thought we in Johnson was gonna go with
what that movie was that instead of like
the Jedi good and the SIF bad that they
were gonna try to make a new standard
we're both like like a boffo duality
that's what I thought was actually gonna
be going down in the full run and I
definitely brought to both movies
between kylo Ren and Rey I actually
liked the interaction with them and the
relationship I was going on with that
said though in this movie leads to my
biggest complaint of the movie where
this should rise the Skywalker's
should've been split into two movies
thing is every single story be over
there it hit me like I can see them
hitting in some way shape or form but
there was not enough time given to the
people to give gravitas to the morning
so continuing to parts unknown
continuing for parts and I'll give you
that
raw exclusive footage true for the Lord
we're gonna continue this so anyway look
we're gonna finish this thing off man
Roger the Skywalker
where we at we're talking about the kylo
Ren thing you know I'm saying so where
we at now as a conclusion to the series
and move for us off I think if you're a
kid who came to Star Wars at the start
of force awakens or even if you've
watched all the movies in the last
couple of years and you're still you
know your teens or whatever yeah I think
it's I think you get a lot of fun out of
that hero arc stuff right the hero story
the heroes path because that's exactly
what this is it's very trophy it's very
safe and I think in doing that they miss
the opportunity to especially
make this second and and this this this
last trilogy have an identity of its own
as much as people did not like the last
Jedi and I didn't like a lot about it
it wasn't afraid to do some different
things and I in retrospect and watching
this one I respect that
now even more and say they necessarily
did a lot of great things with it but
they had the courage to do some
different things
what was the part you felt was
courageous just the the whole killing of
a Jedi thing the thing is if my thing is
that Luke goes back on that in this
movie yeah I was wrong right so exactly
so it's one of those things what you
know what and again that's me that was
where I felt the idea was like this is
course correction and course correcting
you just you made the same II movie you
made the same a movie and just killed
any any opportunity for it to have a
lasting identity I think the original
trilogy
you know I does it hold up as well as it
did when I was 10 years old no I'm 10
years old um but at the same time I
think it had a heart right and it did a
lot of things first right I agree that
you know the following six movies just
mimicked and they were sort of afraid to
really break away from that gotcha and
in the end it's sad cuz I what I'm gonna
remember most about this 9 movie arc all
the ones that I the first ones think
what I saw when I was a kid the class in
general so last question I got to
yourself over the car like do you think
as far as the moving forward do you
think day you would be interested in
still seeing a standalone saga like how
would they move forward like isn't it
over like innocence and that's another
thing right where I think the forces
always been about balance right right
with good they have to you have to have
evil that's my crush
so the story that's told here evil has
been obliterated yeah it was out here
completely obliterated so once again
isn't there's no balance now yeah um
that's bad storytelling
I would be interested in seeing other
types of stories in the Star Wars
universe a la the Mandalorian and things
like that things that take other aspects
of this universe and blow it out in a
way that focuses on character right
character and interactions between
character I've said this about heavily
story-based games and I'll say it about
movies the most important thing isn't
the overarching story you're trying to
tell me it's always about the characters
and do you care about them you care
about what they're doing and you care
about the people that they care about
and if you can nail that everything else
falls into place around it enough know
what Khaybar sue the final one is it
worthy of the trilogy I mean do you feel
any more movies need to come about is it
over like where you act with conclusion
I think there's still a lot more
opportunities in the Star Wars universe
I mean I've shown by the Mandalorian I
have only seen one episode but I've only
seen I've only seen one episode but from
what I've seen those storytellers they
definitely know what's going on with the
Star Wars universe and because of the
Mandalorian and it's not strictly good
versus evil there's a little more
there's a little more leeway into giving
more like more
I wouldn't say interactive from stories
with more gravitas to it and so for the
movie itself I mean I can't say for any
of the big fans but I can understand why
they would to be disappointed right but
as a movie as a movie viewer they stated
it already fries the Skywalker's has
been split into two movies right had
good moments that could actually have if
they hadn't expanded on in further
scenes would have hit a lot harder but
with the rush nature they just fell flat
so would you want to see another movie
spin-off like it is their basis based on
the evil based on poverty's out of here
right now
like is there do you feel there's a room
for anything to continue forward or
anything should be like a prequel old
stuff yeah but they can always talk
about that it's man is always gonna lust
for power and whether it may not be sift
or otherwise they can always make a
villain and that's shown by the recent
game the Jedi fold in order which is
outstanding
which is outstanding they can they can
make stories without the heavy hitters
doing like doing that have doing the
heavy weight lifting I mean so but I
think they need to say we're from the
children's I think everyone needs to get
away from doing that or let's do the
trilogy's to make it majestic just make
a story on his own if it takes one movie
or it takes five movies do it but don't
limit yourself to just three because
otherwise you're gonna get rise to
Skywalker we have it I mean for me like
I said I've never taken the Star Wars
series too seriously you know um you
know as a result though I'm not excusing
the movie there were definitely some
parts that from a plot wise I felt it
was rushed I mean other things I would
say like Redemption arcs you know kind
of contrived on certain levels you know
there wasn't feel-good moments for me
III did filled it with some feel-good
moments I felt um obviously that the
callbacks were emotional in certain
levels if you're a fan of that stuff if
you followed it for a while back but
that's why I agree with you they were
going hard with fanservice it almost
felt like a Redemption we've got to get
the Star Wars hardcore back on our side
I kind of do that's the vibe I got from
it and the only thing I I'm again in
Star Wars
for you know from the story like you
said it's always been a balance with the
good and the evil
you know the Sith his whole plan
probably teen was to make her kill show
the hate she takes over
that's a born it now so now there's no
evil in a sense so to me it felt like a
conclusion conclusion like they're done
you know I'm saying kind of thing but I
mean we didn't get this money to be made
to be made but I think they said like
this is the end of Skywalker saga yeah I
don't know that you can take it any
further I don't know that I want to see
these characters again simply because
the way the way it ended it just it just
feels like they went out of their way to
have everyone have such a feel got a
sort of feel-good moment Redemption arcs
and everything then I would I would find
that even more contrived that they tried
to bring them back in that he it's funny
because when you look at the original
trilogy there was a moment when he sat
down with Anakin right for he before he
changed them and he told the story what
he was telling the story of his
Master so do you know like the sieve
they could only be two at a time right
they could only be a master and a
student right that's it right so that
was a Darth Plagueis that was his man
that was his master he told him the
story of how he killed his master to
moon and that's why I can't write any
and in doing so he sort of absorbed
plages his power and it's my
understanding right which was a power
that allows him to sort of defy death
gotcha okay and you know if you caught
that in the original trail and you want
out the original trilogy though the
prequel trilogy then maybe you could
have inferred that that he would come
back at some point were you buying last
thing were you buying what both of you
buying the whole race lineage parenting
the whole did you guys buy that when you
cool with her being a Palpatine so to
speak oh yeah I was I mean the fact but
once again it was too perfect it's too
perfect and I get it like they're
telling her story it was just it just
it's just it doesn't feel like yeah you
gotta understand like I don't know I've
changed my taste of changes as I've
grown up like I want to see intricate
stories and this wasn't an intricate
story when you look at it one safe very
safe and like I said in essence if you
look at every single movie in some way
shape or form
they've just recycled and regurgitated
certain tropes and means nothing over
and it's in the end you just you told
one super-long singular art right that
all it's the very basic battle between
good and evil and to be honest the
people that represented evil all were
all redeemed except the ultimate you
yeah and he got what was coming to him
like I honestly I just want I want more
courage yeah I feel again is this a
great point so I was killing it right
now I think the last thing I'll say is
that sometimes when it's a series with
this kind of history with this kind of
backing you know I think of like video
games like there's such a fan base so I
think what it is is the courage to do
what you want which would actually
probably take it to the next level
they're so afraid of probably pissing
off that hardcore
in doing it and I think maybe is it a
little bit of backlash with the looping
from last you know one people were livid
a lot of my hardcore guys were livid
with that so again I get it you know
it's a tough situation to be in you know
as a director also changing directors
that's tough too but look my feeling and
you know above average I thought I would
rate it you know saying would you guys
yeah it's done I mean in the words of
kylo Ren he was like you forget the past
kill it if you have to they said after
The Truman Show yay what else is on oh
damn already are with the Lord's you
know silly location last but we still
gonna get it done you know and of course
you could catch I'll or podcast on
Sundays 11:00 a.m. probably last 11 a.m.
of 2019 before we go back I addict King
you're gonna be happy is coming back and
of course catch the last word with
myself and he boxes on Fridays and of
course king of the statues my man King
Lord King David with those hot statues
but yeah that's what we got man
roundtable reviews live and direct Star
Wars Roger Skywalker everybody enjoy
your day peace
[Music]